[Music]
foreign
for the Press preview it's our first
look at tomorrow's front pages and
tonight we're going to have a look at
the headlines with huff post UK's
political editor Kevin Schofield who's
joined by The Spectators economics
editor Kate Andrews great to see you
both we will chat in a moment after
we've told you about those front pages
starting with the express carrying a
warning that nurses strikes could last
until Christmas
the eye says the government is hopeful
that fractures among unions could spoil
any proposed industrial action while the
Metro hears that the NHS is spending a
million pounds a week drafting in
private ambulances to cover the gaps
when their own Fleet of emergency
vehicles is overstretched
the guardian is focusing tomorrow on
another part of the Health Service
that's under strain reporting that a
quarter of a million children have
missed out on access to mental health
treatment
while the male has seen figures
suggesting that six and a half thousand
sexual assaults are committed in the
country's hospitals each week
the times leads with a speech by the
Prime Minister tomorrow where he'll call
for changes to make sure all adults
learn to do at least basic maths
according to the Ft the bank of England
May revamp its deposit guarantee scheme
which protects people's savings
and the chap on the front of the Stars
perhaps a little over excited that it's
going to be 20 degrees in some parts of
the country tomorrow
and don't forget you can scan the QR
code that you see on screen during the
program have a look for yourself at the
front pages while you watch us
discussing them and to do that Kate
Andrews and Kevin Schofield are here
great to see you this Sunday evening
let's start with the nurses strike shall
we Kate front of the Daily Express
nurses worn strikes could last all year
MPS and the prime minister of course
back to work after the Easter break
tomorrow this is the sort of headline
that uh Rishi sunat will not want to be
seeing
well after last week's
record-long NHS walkout that involved
the junior doctors everyone from the
healthcare workers to the government to
of course patients are asking what's
next and the Royal College of Nursing
rejected the pay deal that had been
struck with the government last month
its members voted to reject that and so
now the question is to what extent will
nurses stage bigger walkouts they will
be voting again
um next month and that has you know
raised some questions as to whether or
not the members want to be striking all
year but at the moment it seems like it
certainly could be a possibility and
there is speculation although it's
denied in some papers sort of hinted at
in others uh that the nurses and the
junior doctors May team up so to speak
in order to put more pressure on the
government uh to to give them salary
boost of course there is more public
sympathy at the moment for the nurses
and the junior doctors there's a slight
majority in most polls for the junior
doctors but the nurses are are well
ahead so I think you know there are
question marks over whether or not that
would be an efficient thing for the RCN
to do but we certainly could be looking
down the barrel of many more strikes in
the coming weeks and months at a time
when the waitlist in NHS England is well
above 7 million and Counting uh yeah
looking at the front of the times very
similar headline actually for them NHS
nurses threatened to strike until
Christmas
um Kevin
um what do you make especially at that
point uh that Kate was making there Pat
Cullen leader of the RCN saying there
are no plans on the nurses side for
coordinated industrial action but she
didn't explicitly rule it out did she
no she's not ruling it out I mean Pat
Cullen is in a bit of an awkward
position herself because the she had
recommended to the RCN leadership had
recommended to the members that they
accept this deal and said at the time
that it was the best deal that that they
could get after months of talks with the
government and now she's having to
obviously go back in and and call on
Steve Barclay to come up with more money
now thus far certainly writing in the
sun on Sunday this morning Steve Barclay
gave no indication that more money would
be forthcoming I don't think uh the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt is in favor of um
increasing the offer so it's a bit of a
difficult one for both sides now
obviously adding to the confusion
actually is the fact that um Unison
members who are nurses they voted to
accept the deal
um on Friday so uh there's a split in
the ranks there obviously other unions
are balancing as well I think the
government now wants to wait to see what
the result is of those
uh ballots to to
um illustrate uh whether or not the RCN
is an outlier or whether it's
representative of the majority of nurses
so yeah I think a lot hinges on the
results of those
um ballots and then of course then the
RCN themselves once these strikes at the
end of the month the 48 are strike that
they've got planned once that is out of
the way they are rebalancing to see
whether they can get a renewed mandate
from their members for as as Pat Khan
said uh strikes going on all the way up
until Christmas so uh so yeah as you say
it's not great for Rishi sunic I think
he had hoped that the public sector
strikes were coming to an end they did
manage to reach agreement with a few
unions earlier in the year but you know
we've now got the junior doctors are
still
um at loggerheads with the government
teachers as well civil servants and
obviously nurses so yeah it's um it's
not looking great on the public sector
strikes front yeah I know and those
splits that you're talking about between
between the unions
um Kate are on the front of the eye in
their headline ministers pin hopes of
end to Nursery strikes on Union splits
ever paid deal uh making the point that
um uh ministers believe the RCN could
struggle to win that second ballot for
strike action um when it does consult
its members because um the other unions
are more happy with it
well this would be the best outcome from
the government and I should point out
that's a pretty low bar at this point
given the fact that these strikes have
been going on for months and
negotiations have been a real struggle
but the best case scenario is that the
RCN and the second ballot does not see
the majority of its members want to keep
striking until Christmas and the Unison
um uh decision will will certainly weigh
on people's minds and weigh on other
nurses Minds the fact that they did
accept this pay deal
um I think this week is going to produce
some quite interesting data usually you
can't make too much out of monthly data
when it comes to anything from the labor
market to GDP figures but we do have new
inflation data out this week and you
know one of the government's strong
talking points for everybody not just
for public sector unions is that the
rate of inflation is going to come down
quite rapidly this year that is their
prediction
um it has been a really tough start to
the year we actually saw the rate of
inflation increase slightly in the last
update but if we start to see meaningful
movement on that figure I suspect the
government will double down in its
position that around the five percent
pay raise is what they can realistically
offer and when it comes to the rate of
inflation and also just looking at the
state of the government finances at the
moment in the very precarious position
that they're in after covid of course if
the rate of inflation keeps ticking up
becomes much harder for the government
to make that argument uh so you know I
I'm going to be looking at that data
this week I think that we'll be uh
interesting but you know the
overwhelming question I think Still
Remains Not so much about pay but about
how this is impacting on patients there
have been real warnings from NHS
Representatives about the impact that
these strikes are having on patients it
is obviously in everybody's interest to
bring this to an end so
um you know that does put significant
pressure on government almost regardless
of the data uh to continue to try to be
uh to you know try to get the unions to
the table to have these conversations
and vice versa because the longer
doctors and nurses are out of Hospital
you know the harder it is for the
patients who are desperately need in
those appointments yeah I was the boss
of the the NHS Confederation wasn't it
on sky today Matthew Taylor um I think
his name is saying that this action
Kevin could endanger patience safety and
dignity
yeah well that's right I mean they're
saying I've said that they will
intensify their industrial action
um in this 48 hour strike that's that's
coming at the end of the month by
um not having opt-outs for nurses uh in
Cancer Care Wards accident and emergency
intensive care and in the previous
strikes they have not been on strike
because they also need to provide care
for people in that situation but they've
said you know that will not take place
the next time so that obviously
increases the chances of of of people
not getting the the Urgent Care that
they need and I thought it was
interesting as well this morning that
we're streeting uh labor Shadow Health
secretary uh when he was on the media
around this morning he said that labor
can't support these strikes now either
because of the risk to patient safety
which I think is pretty pretty
significant coming from a labor
politician yeah I thought that was
interesting as well okay well let's move
on um it seems every time that I present
the Press preview there's another
depressing headline about Children's
Mental Health Kate and tonight is no
exception with their Splash on the front
of the Guardian
yeah this is a research carried out by
House Magazine and shared with the
guardian that finds that um roughly 250
000 children uh with mental health
problems have been turned away
essentially denied help on the NHS
um and this is a result of them having
to raise the threshold for what would
qualify as getting access to NHS
services in 2021-2022 because the demand
for these Services has skyrocketed so
rapidly
um obviously the strikes aren't helping
but this isn't really a strike story
that the Mental Health crisis within the
NHS has been going on for years and made
so much worse by the pandemic and the
impact of lockdowns and laws education
for these children
um and you know as you say Jonathan is
depressing I mean it's really terrifying
stuff the many hundreds of thousands of
children that are being denied access to
mental health care for whom you know we
can assume most of those parents won't
really have anywhere else to turn and
denying them access to treatment now can
lead to serious complications down on
the road uh you know it's um a reminder
how limited resources are in the current
structure and that we are disappointing
and letting down arguably the most
vulnerable who are in the most need of
the Care yeah and so varied the care
isn't it Kevin depending on where you
live
yeah your postcode a lot today and some
areas spending four times as much as
others on mental uh Health Services for
adolescents and children
um which is you know almost as as
worrying as the fact that um so many are
not getting any treatment whatsoever so
a lot obviously depends on where you
live
um will uh dictate what kind of
um treatment or quality of care that you
get so uh so yeah it's a really
important piece of Journalism I think
this uh hats off to the house magazine
for uncovering these figures and it's an
incumbent now I think on politicians and
for the government to respond to this
I'm sure there'll be searching questions
being asked in Parliament this week now
the MPS are back from from the Easter
break because you know this is something
that cuts across all boundaries uh class
boundaries racial boundaries whatever
you know it can be anyone's children who
can be affected by this and
um yeah this is something that really
needs to be addressed because it is a
problem which is only increasing and
it's another example of the The Strain
and the pressure that the National
Health Service is under yeah I was
speaking to the teacher yesterday he was
saying that she's never known anything
like it in terms of the number of
children in her class and she's a
primary school teacher needing needing
help and I see here a quote from uh the
head of external Affairs at the Charity
Young mine saying uh This research shows
a system in total shutdown Kate with no
clear government plan to solve it
yeah I think that's about right it sums
it up
um of course the NHS is on track in a
few years time to account for roughly 45
of day-to-day government spending and it
isn't that money isn't being put into
the NHS but time and time again we find
that it just isn't funneling to the
front lines it isn't funneling to pay
raises for the staff and it doesn't seem
to be funneling to Patient Care you know
I think the system has a lot to answer
for here
um and and no doubt this needs to be
prioritized and and the government is
ultimately responsible because the
government runs the NHS so you know they
need to come up with some kind of
solution here but
um you know we are we are stuck in a
really terrible system where the
Monopoly health care provider that
people are dependent on just is not
providing for them and in this case it's
children children that are struggling
with mental health issues because of a
really difficult past few years it is it
is heartbreaking it's also unjustifiable
um and uh you know as Kevin said has off
to the uh for House Magazine and the
guardian for flagging this because I
suspect this is going to be one the
stories of the decade the impact of the
past few years on children and how
they're going to grow up with that
Legacy